eine these heute abend ist der
verbrenner darf nicht sterben denn mich
hat heute etwas geärgert der kompromiss
der eu zum verbrenner aus wird gerade
gefeiert aber er geht überhaupt nicht
weit genug was ist eigentlich passiert
jetzt wird erst mal ein bisschen trocken
bleiben die umweltminister der 27 eu
staaten hatten sich darauf geeinigt dass
ab 2035 nur noch klimaneutrale neuwagen
verkauft werden sollen zusätzlich hat
dann die fdp die gut wofür sich aber die
fdp feiert als kompromiss einen
vorschlag gemacht wie nach 2035
fahrzeuge zugelassen werden können die
ausschließlichen klimaneutralen
kraftstoffe näfels betrieben werden als
pro marktwirtschaftler rinn geht mir
aber dieser kompromiss überhaupt nicht
weit genug ich sehe generell das verbot
einer technologie als kritisch an der
verbrenner ist der kern unserer
industrie die deutsche industrie hat
viel viel mehr wettbewerbsvorteile beim
verbrenner als beim batterie elektroauto
alle die in deutschland das verbrenner
aus also herbei sehen wie vor mit
umweltministerin steffi lemke segen mal
wieder hoch motiviert an dem ast auf dem
wir alle sitzen bei alle anderen
eu-länder haben kleine oder keine
autoindustrie also ich bin ich diesmal
auch vereinfacht formulieren darf würde
spanien seine strände sperren um natur
und meerestiere zu schützen natürlich
nicht spanien braucht den tourismus
apropos umwelt das batteriebetriebene
elektroauto ist jetzt auch nicht die
ganz glorreiche umwelt lösung aktuelle
batterien brauchen nämlich die rohstoffe
aus china kongo russland wir wissen ja
alle wie schwierig diese geopolitische
abhängigkeit für uns ist stichwort
atomkraft
dementsprechend bin ich fest davon
überzeugt dass die politik einfach den
markt entscheiden lassen soll wenn ein
kunde mit seinen ganz persönlichen
lebensumständen sich dafür entscheidet
dass ein batterie elektro auto besser
ist wird er dieses auf kaufen ohne zwang
und zum richtigen preis aber die politik
soll endlich auch wenn unternehmer zu
spielen
und wir sind ja letztlich stolz darauf
dass wir auch eine autonation sind da
sind wir dann nicht mehr also
elektroautos für mich keine sache der
upper class wäre es schlau wer holt sich
das ein paar gelder aus den fördertöpfen
und dass wenn ich menschen in den autos
sieht das sind alles gut angezogene
leute ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
der aber da sich ein e auto leisten kann
oder jemand der auf dem land lebt wie
sollen sich das vorstellen da steht man
dann wenn ich dann in zum arzt in
nächste stadt muss ich erstmal die
steckdose oder so ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen wir müssen autonation bleiben
also für dich ist das e auto deen
typische grüne klientel politik absolut
ich geb dem auto auch eine chance aber
tatsächlich muss es wirklich so sein
dass ich mir dass am ende auch leisten
kann und dass ich dann fahren kann wenn
ich auch fahren will und nicht noch an
die steckdose muss herr bode erfahren
sie in ein elektroauto ein verbrenner
ich könnte nie so tief sinken wie ein
elektroauto zu kaufen das geht gar nicht
außerdem bin ich schon muss in eine
völlig zustimmen ich finde es auch
einfach unanständig dass der arbeiten
sie erwähnt haben denken eine mittel-
oder oberklässler das elektroauto mit
finanziert weil er die steuern zeit von
dundee auto prämien bezahlt vorsichtig
also jemanden sehen denn umwelt schon
ein luxus eines elektroautos kauft wird
von uns allen von den dummen hier noch
mit 9000 euro pro stück glaub ich
unterstützt und das ist ja gerade eine
einheit wir können in unseren verbrenner
rein wir machen das verbrenner auto an
und fahren einfach los
umwelt schonen
die herstellung wenig umweltschonende
entsorgung ist es nicht aber trotzdem
teilige aufregung nicht weil daraus wird
nichts wir können sondern liste von
sachen auf studium beschlossen hat die
nicht durchgekommen sind zum beispiel
keine vergesellschaftung der schulden
nicht wahr und andere kleinigkeiten
sie haben wir 20 22h 35 soll der elektro
motor nicht mehr hergestellt und
ausgeliefert werden das sind 12 13 jahre
nicht wahr in den 23 10 jahren kann viel
passieren und ich finde ein zeichen von
optimismus und verantwortlichkeit
prognosen über zwölf jahre hinweg zu
machen die sie haben während deckt das
die bundeswehr ist das deutsche
straßennetz runderneuert werden aus
lauter überraschungen und hier machen
die pläne zwölf jahre im voraus wissen
sie in zwölf jahren werden wir eine
chinesische provinz sein wenn wir glück
haben wir kein glück haben sind ja
eigentlich nicht so dass ein arabisches
land ich mag sie wirklich sehr aber das
finde ich so wenig macht extrem wir
fanden einfach nicht vorstellen was
kostet dann solitär öko benzin ist er
dann billiger oder teurer keiner noch
nicht das ist doch ein zufall dass wir
das auch nicht erfahren
wir sind nur überall glückliche leute
ich will deinen kampagne die anderen
laufen viel
kakophonie kannte nicht geben weil die
herstellung energie intensiven weil sie
ganz viele voraussetzungen das weiß man
noch nicht wie es bis bis halt dann 2035
ist mit e fuß oder auch wasserstoff also
ob es dann möglich ist dass die
klimaneutral sind auch die verbrenner
durchlaufen die auch mit kölnisch wasser
und wir wissen es nicht aber ich wollte
jetzt frau treuenfels frowein christian
lender unser finanzminister und fdp boss
hat ja heute getwittert nein zum
verbrenner aus dann hab ich mir das
alles mal ganz genau angeschaut und so
ganz groß ist das nein von der eu ja
nicht es ist ja nur ein kompromiss
gefunden wie eine hintertür wie sehen
sie das denn na ja an die fdp heute
feiern dann zu feiern finde ich es
deswegen kein grund möglicher kein
geheimnis dass wir immer gesagt haben
wir sagen auf keinen fall macht wieder
mit aber es ist ein kompromiss gefunden
worden und zumindestens haben wir
rausgeholt dass jetzt die kommission
einen vorschlag erarbeiten soll und da
gebe ich ihnen recht mal sehen was da so
kommt das ver brenner weiter zugelassen
werden wenn sie mittels getankt werden
ist ja schon mal mehr als wenn man
gleich da diesem mainstream zeugt ich
selber sehe das ist ich sehe ich sehe es
ein bisschen so wie sie ich glaube muss
das ein bisschen entspannter sehen ich
glaube auch ehrlich gesagt dass die
autoindustrie ein bisschen mehr schafft
als wie heute denke ich glaube nicht
dass wir daran jetzt zu grunde gehen als
1 und meine zweite these ist ich finde
mehr so die infrastruktur die
ladeinfrastruktur das ist doch das
problem wenn viele autos auf den markt
kommt werden sie nicht mehr
subventioniert dann kann sich die glaube
ich auch jeder leisten da muss man jetzt
nicht zwischen arm und reich trennen das
würde ich glaube ich nicht so sehen aber
die infrastruktur herzustellen einer
stadt zum beispiel mit einer wohnung ist
doch jetzt schon so in hamburg das
stimmt die grünen fahren eine solche
autos ich weiß nicht wo tappen die diese
autos eigentlich dass das glaube ich
eher das problem ich würde sagen dass
man muss das bisschen runter wir hoffen
wir haben gesagt das wird funktionieren
das wird uns nicht kaputt machen lassen
dass sie nicht gerne machen aber jetzt
wenn ich wirklich mal auf die atomkraft
zurück schaue da hat man ja auch gesagt
das wird alles mit den erneuerbaren
energien würde klappen jetzt sind wir
unfassbar abhängig und die meisten viele
bereuen sind jetzt begeben wir uns also
wieder in die geopolitische abhängigkeit
obwohl wir beim verbrenner wirklich in
deutschland die absoluten also das ist
unsere dna das können wir waren schon
wieder zu was was wir können sagen nein
goodbye von seiten der politik anstatt
nicht die autoindustrie lösungen finden
zu lassen mit technologieoffenheit und
auch mit vorgaben das ist immer weiter
runter das ist ja genau was ich auch
denke aber nun da stehen ja wirklich so
dass ich auch kein geheimnis dass wir so
denken aber es ist nun mal so dass es
auch keine haben dass das ein kompromiss
gefunden werden muss und wir haben uns
in vielen dingen bis jetzt als fdp gut
durchgesetzt unter rot-grün werde gleich
noch ein bisschen schlimmer geworden so
es ist ein kompromiss ist ein kapitel
sie ein kompromiss ist kein wert an sich
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt glaube
ich fertig war das wäre kompromissen
strother straße folgen es gibt es
dazwischen ich sage er wird das find ich
kann mir jetzt nicht vergleichen doch
vielen dank für den eintrag findet
trotzdem und dabei bleibe ich ja man
muss ein bisschen entspannter sehen ich
glaube nicht dass die autoindustrie
daran kaputt geht weil mich wundert
immer dass viele autos training ist riet
mir auch sagen also mit denen ich
spreche doch wir finden das gut ich
wundere mich darüber ich finde mal so
ich dachte früher immer so wir als fdp
sagen soll technologieoffenheit und bos
kg autos und viele vertreter nur wir
sind das studentische
automobilzulieferer denken immer nur an
die großen konzerne das rückgrat der
deutschen wirtschaft sind die
familienunternehmen jahren eigentlich
die mittelständler absolute top im
sauerland oder woanders und da muss man
auch ganz klar sagen viele
automobilzulieferer finde es nicht gut
wenn sie sagen jetzt nicht das ist das
glück zahlt sich auf jeden fall klar ja
und ich finde es auch nicht richtig gut
also meine ich ich sage was ich denke ja
es ist ja nicht so dass ich sagen würde
ich finde ich jetzt richtig prima und
das müssen wir fürs klima tun so denke
ich ja nicht ich finde auch das muss der
markt entscheiden ist das ja auch immer
unsere auffassung gewesen es ist aber
nun so wie es ist und ich will mich doch
nicht verarschen denken wir haben alles
zugestimmt aber ich denke trotzdem dass
christian da schon sehr deutlich gemacht
und da wird ja auch sicher hinterher
sein dass dieser vorschlag ist sich in
schall und rauch verschwindet sondern
dass das dann auch passiert
ein statisch steht denn die politik für
kompromisse vielleicht auch für faule
kompromisse wofür steht für sie die
politik nicht find sie hat im moment
etwas sehr ideologisch ist also wir
haben ja schon energiewende und die
erneuerbaren die können das alles diese
technologie geschlossenheit sagen wir
mal beim thema
motorantrieb dass man ganze sachen
ausblendet also meines wissens ist
toyota hält die wasserstoff den
wasserstoffantrieb für
vielversprechendsten investiert da rein
also man schießt sich irgendwie bisschen
vermessen
planwirtschaftlich schießt sich auf
irgendwelche ziele 1 und bleibt dann bei
der einen technologie jetzt bei der
energiewende glaube ich noch dass das
gar nicht funktionieren kann also das
einfach physisch nicht möglich ist war
da halt winter flauten haben weil wir
zeiten haben wo die sonne gar nicht
scheint also man fühlt sich ein bisschen
mao tse tung habe ich neulich eine
sendung darüber gesehen über seinen
großen sprung nach vorne wo die die
bauern dann irgendwelche hochöfen in
ihren hinterhöfen bauen mussten und ihre
band da sign gewagter vergleich also
völlig wertlosen stahl eigentlich
produziert haben und dafür sehe ich
schon in deutschland erinnert wenn sie
das sehen ja
dieses sich einschießen dieses dieser
patriotismus ist vielleicht nicht aber
die energiewende hat schon so ein
bisschen was und alle anderen sind
natürlich geisterfahrern die engländer
die finden die ihre atomkraftwerke
behalten oder auch noch ausbauen das
sind die wir sind die vorreiter und die
sind alles sind alles geisterfahrer ich
würde können wir denn auch die frage
würde ich gerne meinen sie richten am
ende denn dann auch ohne autoindustrie
leben wenn ich jetzt sagen wie die
konzerne schaffen ist nicht die
elektroautos da sind wir jetzt doch
nicht die marktführer weltweit wie wir
das dann aussehen naja das natürlich
nicht also ich meine ich kann jetzt auch
nicht das ist kaffeesatzleserei das
können dass ich wirklich nicht sagen
aber ich denke auf keinen fall können
wir das natürlich gehört das zu uns ja
aber dennoch glaube ich man muss ja
irgendwie erstmal glaube ich ist der weg
viel länger als wir denken da stimme ich
ihnen ganz gut das könnte man bisschen
entspannter sehen was die sich da so
ausdenken ist eben dauert ja mal ein
bisschen dass es umgesetzt wird aber ich
glaube schon dass die autoindustrie
umstellen kann das ist ja was auch so
deutschlands wirtschaft ausmacht dass
die schnell auch neue lösungen finden
dass das jetzt auf dieses elektroauto so
kapriziert das finde ich auch falsch
weil gesagt möchte ich nun offen hat
dann muss auch diese offenheit sein und
nicht irgendwie wir geben vor und dieser
ein bisschen hinterher produzieren also
sehen das ganze ist doch dass kaisers
neue kleider die leute wissen dass es
nicht gehen wird die eu hat mehrere
jahre gebraucht um eine verordnung für
die herstellung von schnullern
herauszugeben
solche gibt es 100 die können das
einfach nicht schaffen damit wir müssen
diesen therapeutischen zirkus
veranstalten damit der eindruck entsteht
die machen was er sind viele
technologien hier abgeschafft worden
deutschland wird nie wieder irgendwann
atomkraftwerk bauen das unternehmen
jetzt die russen und die chinesen und
die fahrt sollten die franzosen und
anderer unter entwickeln nationen die
nicht unserer hohen moralischen
standards haben hier ist die
genforschung praktisch abgeschafft
worden es gibt keine stammzellen
forschung in deutschland hat sich auch
sehr viel im verabschiedet und irgendwie
geht es immer weiter aber war
atomkraftwerke also dass das würde ich
jetzt gar nicht unbedingt sagen wir
zumindestens finden also ich finde das
jedenfalls dass wir auch dass sich
ausschließen können dass wir können
jetzt nicht irgendwie in schmutziger
kohle investieren und sagen das finden
wir jetzt wieder prima wo er vorher
alles das immer mit wollen wir das
atomkraftwerk philippsburg in sich
zusammengefallen wie auch immer ich will
nur sagen da würde ich sagen also das
ist auch in der politik ich weiß ja aus
bei den grünen angekommen ist die haben
sich ja lange ein bisschen rausgehen
brennstäben rauf und runter und alle
dachten okay das geht alles gar nicht
jetzt hat sich herausgestellt dass es
doch geht ja und dann muss man das auch
machen wir sind alle situationen haben
wir gerade richtig gesagt wir waren
richtig abhängig davon russland werde
daraus sollen und die preise nicht total
hochgehen lassen wollen da muss man das
machen ganz einfach